I ask you another question cuz I wrote
this down cuz you were talking and I
wanted to write this down I want to get
your [ __ ] opinion about those a couple
of times when I've been on the road the
middle act who I fly out or whoever will
always go well sometimes go it's gonna
take off while you're on stage I'm just
gonna go take off no you're not I always
go you're going fun hmm
you know me and then they take off but
then when I'm on stage I'm thinking
about them the whole time I'm getting
loud I'm like wow
yeah I worked I was getting ready to a
special and I worked with a person I
won't say anything won't say anything
this is by the way this is I mean this
is and I worked with a person and I and
I got off stage Thursday also sold out
right great room great room
Portland helium I like that yeah
Thursday and I go to the green room I'm
like where's dr. thought they're like oh
they went home I went oh that's why I
texted him I said are you feeling sick
they said no just get into bed early
I went cool Friday to shows after the
first show they're not home they went
for a walk like they got off stage and
went for a walk
show back up for the second show and I
was like hey you gonna hang out tonight
and they're like now probably not I know
it okay
Saturday comes around and I'm [ __ ]
fuming I'm you and I say hey just so you
know you're not that funny I didn't
bring you here because I think you're
brilliant
you're not here because you're funny at
all you're here because I need someone
to be around I can't be by myself around
and now I'm now I'm stuck I would rather
do a one-man show if you're not gonna be
here yeah and and that person was like
oh okay well I can hang out tonight and
I was like yeah oh no
you're going to hang out tonight yes it
of that bar you gonna drink I don't care
if you're in [ __ ] rehab you're gonna
and they're gonna tell me how great my
show was you're watching my whole show
Wow I was like what the [ __ ] yeah when I
was when I was coming up dude it was so
[ __ ] different I would open for Jay
Mohr and I would sit back watch Jays
entire set I watched every I could
recite Jay morissette verbatim I knew if
I can't if there was a tag I'd run in I
tell him at a guy came up joke ideas
that was I was I was part of the JJ
Train it was I my job was it to go in
and murder
I mean and and Jay never made it like
clear like hey man you know I didn't
just bring you here to murder yeah and I
was murdering at those shows I mean it
was sold out yeah [ __ ] tits to tits
and you could destroy it was such a good
comedy crowd and my job was not that was
it was what does anyone do after like
and I he didn't he didn't say it I just
knew I'm here for him I'm not here to
just murder yes let me tell you
something when you were you got me real
emotional just now man let me say
something to you my friend okay
I've opened for many people as well back
in the 90s Paulie Carlos Mencia you can
say what you want about him but I didn't
know and I every moment of it you
appreciate
oh I carried the golf bags I would go up
I would go to mencius house early when
we're flying out to pick up his merge
and go to the airport and do that I
would watch all the shows I would hang
out after the show
right do you know why because it's
number one it's I'm it's all it's an
honor it's a [ __ ] honor number two
I'm a learning and number three what was
I doing before I was like waiting tables
and you want this what an opportunity
dude these kids now [ __ ] oh good oh my
god these kissing they have no gratitude
[Laughter]
bro it's like they don't they don't
thank you
right they did they sit there like they
have attitude
it's right yeah how was the week I was
sold out shows did you have fun yeah
that's alright [ __ ] you man oh man no
gratitude what I'm saying is that you
know it's um
it's a difficult business to go into
yeah right and you are the same as I
write we bring young people right and
when we want to give them opportunity
that's what it is is opportunity you
know I took Nicole Aimee Schreiber to
the Schomburg improv sold on every show
and um that's a good weekend and the
managers came up to Nicole and goes hey
you're really funny
can you we would like to headline you on
off nights and she was super grateful
right now and that's what it's all about
the opportunity that is given to you I
had a guy open for me in New York I'll
say his name I'll see his name what's
his name Freddy Lockhart do you know him
yeah yeah you're not gonna believe this
because I think he I love a Facebook
page he does he's a great guy Freddy
you're a great great great comic great
work on face and you [ __ ] up one time
and I'm about to share that all right
you [ __ ] up one time about to share it
all right and I love you your diverse
you have you have first yeah I love your
diversity you're physically funny and
you're anomaly and I love it okay but
this [ __ ] this so it was a pay with a
care lines and he's featuring and he has
a pretty good set and as we're crossing
each other he looks at her he goes
follow that you know me he's trying to
bury you right Wow I know Freddy what's
a-happening hot stuff
I know when I'm my point is or does that
racist at all where the majority of
comedic devices are just be gay like I
got herpes simplex to take a banana
[Music]
Freddy no my point is is that but that
was but the generation I grew up with it
is it's just about respect and I don't
know these kids today I don't know what
happened